revisemos un poco lo que hemos aprendido
de cálculo diferencial supongamos que
tenemos la función s que nos da en
función del tiempo la posición de una
partícula en una dimensión si tomamos la
derivada con respecto al tiempo si
tomamos la derivada de s con respecto al
tiempo que obtenemos bueno obtenemos por
supuesto la derivada de s con respecto
al tiempo que es la razón de cambio de
la posición con respecto al tiempo que
también se designa como la velocidad
así es que esto es la velocidad que
también es una función que depende del
tiempo ahora si derivamos nuevamente con
respecto al tiempo si derivamos con
respecto al tiempo la velocidad que
estaríamos de hecho tomando la segunda
derivada con respecto al tiempo de la
posición que es la primera derivada con
respecto al tiempo de la velocidad
obtendríamos entonces debe en dt que es
la derivada de la velocidad con respecto
al tiempo esto es la razón de cambio de
la velocidad con respecto al tiempo
lo cual se denomina aceleración esto es
la aceleración que también es una
función que depende del tiempo así es
que empezamos con la posición como una
función del tiempo tomamos la derivada
de la posición para obtener la velocidad
tomamos la derivada de la velocidad para
obtener la aceleración pero también
podríamos ir en sentido contrario si
conocemos la aceleración podríamos tomar
la anti derivada de la aceleración
podríamos tomar la anti derivada de esta
aceleración y que obtendríamos
obtendríamos bueno déjame mejor
escribirlo de la siguiente manera voy a
usar el símbolo de la integral
indefinida
así es que tomo la integral de la
aceleración con respecto al tiempo y
esto me va a dar una cierta expresión
más una constante c es decir voy a poder
determinar la forma general de la
velocidad pueda determinar la velocidad
más una constante que voy a poder
evaluar con un valor preciso de la
velocidad para cierto tiempo específico
ahora si yo tomo la anti derivada de la
velocidad es decir ahora integró la
velocidad con respecto al tiempo íntegro
la velocidad con respecto al tiempo y va
a obtener lo mismo una expresión general
más una constante ce que me va a
determinar entonces la posición
la posición s dt más cierta constante
que va a poder determinar al conocer un
valor preciso de la posición para un
cierto tiempo habiendo revisado esto y
que también hemos podido ponerlo en
términos de anti derivada es decir
hicimos el planteamiento para derivadas
pero también llegamos a hacer un
planteamiento para anti derivadas
hagamos un problema específico
supongamos que sabemos que la
aceleración de una partícula como
función del tiempo es igual a 1 es decir
nuestro objeto está acelerando de manera
constante a una unidad de digamos vamos
a ponerlo en términos de metros y
segundos
así es que esto va a ser un metro por
segundo cuadrado
va a ser la aceleración en función del
tiempo y supongamos que no sabemos una
expresión para la velocidad pero sabemos
la velocidad a un tiempo específico y
tampoco conocemos una expresión para la
posición pero sabemos la posición a un
tiempo específico
supongamos entonces que la velocidad a
los tres segundos es de menos tres
esto sería metros por segundo vamos a
poner las unidades aquí esto sería
entonces un metro por segundo cuadrado
sería la aceleración la velocidad es
menos tres metros por segundo y
suponemos que la posición
la posición del objeto a los dos
segundos es igual a menos diez metros
estamos en una dimensión esto quiere
decir que el objeto se encuentra a diez
unidades a la izquierda del origen ahora
dada esta información que tenemos y el
desarrollo que hemos hecho acá arriba
podemos obtener una expresión para la
velocidad como función de tiempo no tan
solo la velocidad en un tiempo preciso
sino una expresión para la velocidad
como función de tiempo y también una
expresión para la posición con función
de tiempo te invito a que le pongas
pausa el vídeo e intentes hacer esto por
tu cuenta
veámoslo entonces sabemos que la
velocidad como función del tiempo va a
ser la anti derivada de la aceleración
como función de tiempo la anti derivada
de 1 con respecto al tiempo y esto va a
ser igual a t más una constante c y
ahora podemos encontrar el valor de la
constante pues sabemos que ve de 3 es
igual a menos 3 hagamos eso por acá ve
de 3 es igual en vez de t vamos a
sustituir el valor de 3 b de 3 igual a 3
más c lo que hemos hecho es que en vez
de t hemos sustituido el valor de 3 hay
que ponerlo con otro color para que
quede más claro aquí tengo el 3 que es
el valor de t este 3 lo es sustituido
aquí y esto va a ser igual a menos 3
también lo va a poner con otro color
menos
esto es igual a menos 3 ya podemos
despejar se de aquí despejamos de esta
ecuación que tenemos aquí préstamos 3 a
ambos lados de la igualdad para obtener
entonces que se es igual a menos 6 y ya
tenemos la expresión exacta para la
velocidad como función del tiempo vamos
a ponerla por acá btt es igual a t más
la constante más menos 6 t menos 6 y
podemos verificar esto la derivada de b
con respecto al tiempo es igual a 1 y v
de 3 es igual a 3 menos 6 que es
efectivamente menos 3 ya tenemos
entonces la velocidad en función del
tiempo hagamos ahora lo mismo para
encontrar la posición como función del
tiempo sabemos que la posición es la
anti derivada de la función de velocidad
escribamos esto
la posición como función del tiempo es
anti derivada de la velocidad con
respecto al tiempo esto es la anti
derivada de t menos 6 de t y esto es
igual la anti derivada de t esté
cuadrada sobre 2 eso ya lo sabemos
así es que esto es igual a t cuadrada
sobre 2 - la anti derivada de 6 que es 6
t y por supuesto también hay que sumarle
aquí una constante de integración más c
así es que esto de aquí es igual a ese
de t
esta es la expresión para ese de t vamos
a determinar el valor de la constante
usando la información que tenemos aquí
sabemos que cuando te es igual a 2 la
posición es menos 10 vamos a sustituir
esa información en la expresión de ese
de t así que ese de 2 es igual a 2 al
cuadrado sobre 2 2 al cuadrado es 4
sobre 2 esto es igual a 2 menos
6 por 2 que es 12 + c y esto es igual al
valor de s de 2 que es menos 10 vamos a
agrupar términos semejantes
2 - 12 menos 10
esto nos queda entonces menos 10 + c que
es igual a menos 10 sumamos 10 ambos
lados y obtenemos que se es igual a 0 y
ya hemos obtenido la posición
la constante c es igual a 0
así es que la posición como función del
tiempo nos queda de cuadrada sobre 2
menos 6 y podemos verificar esto cuando
te es igual a 2 2 al cuadrado es 4 sobre
12 es 2 - 12 2 menos 12 es igual a menos
10 si derivamos esto obtenemos menos 6 y
podemos ver como ya lo hicimos que ve de
3 es igual a menos 3 y al tomar la
derivada aquí dvd t obtenemos la
aceleración que es igual a 1 en fin
espero que hayas disfrutado de este
vídeo